[Music]
[Applause]
hamdi welcome to the gsb we are so
excited to have you here thank you thank
you so much this is so hard
it's just a little extra yeah
well campus has been buzzing with your
arrival and in fact there's actually
been a bit of a debate about what is the
best flavor of chobani yogurt
so in this true spirit of business
school i set out to do a bit of market
research and pulled the class
to see
what was the most popular flavor
so out of strawberry peach blueberry and
raspberry hamdi would you like to guess
which flavor one uh it's blueberry
blueberry oh well
actually strawberry one
we at the gsb love to be outliers so
it's okay i understand
[Laughter]
well and then here's some behind the
scenes footage
if you'd like to use these as marketing
materials feel free
in preparation for our conversation i
learned that chobani can be loosely
translated to shepherd can you tell tell
us about the significance there
sure um
and your background is greek as i
understood just now which is beautiful
i mean i don't know if you speak greek
but it's also sounds like chobani but i
i won't kill it it's like sopani
something something like this
and in turkish is choban
and by the way i want to say merhaba to
my turkish brothers and sisters
that they're here
and and of course
all of you i'm just kind of homesick but
um
then
the
i grew i grew up on the eastern part of
turkey
in the northeast
and
nomad
a tribal life
so my earliest memories are with
shepherds
and choban means shepherds i don't so my
earliest memories are all shepherds
shepherd stories
interaction with shepherds
family members being shepherds i was too
little but
being eager to go with them to the
you know caring for the animals
so when i was looking for name
i was traveling from
chicago to madison wisconsin
and the reason for that is i drove from
that road to go to this old equipment
dealership in madison wisconsin so i can
buy this
separator
where it's essential to make greek
yogurt to separate liquid from the from
the mass
and in that drive i don't know if any of
you have done that drive
it's a very boring drive it's a long
drive
not much radio is working it's 2006.
i don't know if i was bored or if it was
the christian radio i was listening that
they were talking about shepherds all
the time
i
came up with the name chobani at that
drive
and when i came back to chicago and i
looked it up and chobani.com was
available and that's how we came up
amazing well we've learned in a lot of
our classes and case studies the
importance of a brand connection and and
that brand history and you obviously
have a fantastic one i really we i
started shepherd's gear foundation day
one a lot of people don't know what
meanings of it um inside the company
people do know
but they had
significance for me was okay
chobani sounds really nice as a sound it
sounds nice
but then
the the emotional
the weight of that world for me was
you know you look at it throughout the
history and
and we can call it the new shepherds now
but you look at throughout the
generations of humankind we look up the
shepherds
and
it represented pureness
it represented unconditional giving it
represented humanity
safety
and wisdom
and i have seen those
in my own experience you know as a
growing up so i thought
if i can bring the elements of those
right from the beginning with the name
into this
company that i'm launching
it would be a great success and i had no
idea how long would i go i had no idea
how far i would make it or if i would be
able to put elements of it in there but
my personal connections but also that
was the idea that giovanni worked really
well well it all started on a small farm
in turkey but now obviously chobani has
found incredible success
there are countless business ideas and
and aspiring founders out there who are
all trying to create the next big thing
in your opinion what are some of the key
magical ingredients that help create a
breakthrough company that scales
oh wow um
and you know
i have to be very honest
i'm not
um
i did not have a previous knowledge or
experience of business
so
my my earlier experience is as i said
with shepherds later on i went to
university in ankara became an activist
started publishing newspapers and got
into trouble with the government and i
had to get out
some experience with the police station
but then out
and then i found myself in upstate new
york working in a farm so basically
i was home again in upstate new york and
not necessarily know
what i was going to do with my life and
there was not a massive urgency of what
i'm going to do with my life i'm really
one thing that i can tell about myself
not in a bragging way is
i was never nervous about life not that
i had anything about it but i didn't
have this urgency of oh i have to do
this or i have to do this
i always had
growing up
you know being up into those moons and
mountains where we grow up as nomads i
was always wondering what was behind the
tallest mountain that we could see
from our tents and i had that curiosity
that what would be beyond those
mountains so my my journey was always i
wonder what life is going to be bringing
so i'm just going to go
and i found out later on that
i was never rigid like i never made
plans that would
stop me
from changing it going this direction in
that direction
i was in a city
in a busy in trying to learn english and
teachers said i had a farm upstate new
york i went up there she said do you
want to stay here i said sure then i
stay and i became a farmer for a year
and a half
and then somebody said there is a
economic development side that they
support businesses
and i went there and they said do you
want to make cheese i said yeah i'd like
to make some cheese
and then later on i saw an ad and said
fully equipped yogurt plant for sale i
said i'll go liquida take a look at it
that evening and i went to look at the
plants right there and i said you know
what i'll buy this place
despite the fact everybody says you
don't have money
you have no idea what you're thinking
there's a big companies leaving
but i was just curious what would it be
like
from that emotion that i had
in that plant so
i'm not in a position to say
what makes
businesses the scale because i've seen a
numerous anonymous businesses in front
of my eye to start and grow became
extremely powerful
but i can tell you what makes joy in
business
if you're a founder
and if you are the
beginning you know starting
person in the journey
i can tell you
that you could have enormous amount of
experiences
through this and for me
it's it is tremendous
i'm a kid from the shepherds
i travel 1000 years i feel like i travel
1000 years if you look at my early
days
i'm in a tribe
where
tradition has not changed for hundreds
of hundreds of years now it's changed
shepherds have cell phones but back then
when i left
it was the same way they made the bother
it was the same way they did the
weddings it was the same way they
grieved it was the same day way
they interacted socially with each other
it had not had changed
so dramatically only time that they
would go see somewhere outside of the
town and we got sick or they went to
military service but outside of that it
was the same thing so for me it's been
an amazing journey
and i had to
you know adjust as
as i went through but
at the true joy true power of business
comes
when you see that it has a direct impact
on people's life
and as it gets successful and bigger
it becomes extremely powerful
and this i had no idea about this until
i started
now
what i can tell you on that one is if
you want to make business
joyful
but also very successful
it has to be embedded very very early on
day one and it truly needs to be
embedded early on and then becomes
magical
but you just don't know how things comes
into life
you just don't know how you find
solutions
people will give you credits 99 of it is
not you it's the environment that you
created or you've been part of to be
created that inputs come from left and
right ideas come from left and right
people become heroes people who become
solution makers
and it becomes this magical environment
and i always said
it's elevated environment
so how do you become make an elevated
environment
yeah money is good
and you can do a lot of things with it
and people get excited about it the
people i hired
that they let go in the factory in that
old factory
that the old factory
old company they just fired them left
them behind and just left this is
another topic that you could talk about
for hours
those same companies are going to be
millionaires
oh maybe lawyers said i shouldn't be
saying this but the factory workers
right but i couldn't
motivate them
if i told them work with me i'm going to
make you a millionaire
maybe but not that great
but if you create an environment and say
these people left you and these people
left us these people left this factory
children this community these farmers
and i've seen this happen where i come
from
this is a responsibility of businesses
happening everywhere
and there is an answer to this we can go
out and scream and
protest and all that kind of stuff or
even though we don't have money even
though we don't have experience even
though we don't have network even though
we don't have that kind of
capability
but we can put ourselves together in
this tiny little town
in this very old factory
and we could dream that this factory can
become one of the biggest factor in this
country in next five years
and we could dream that we could be a
number one brand in this country and we
can kick those people as we close this
factory and we can give the answer to
them this way
and you can talk to pure four factory
workers that way
and if you truly act upon it you can
make them believe as much as you believe
and that magic starts happening
now in that moment
if you say physically this is not
possible
because in order for you to be
a number one brand in five years a
billion dollars in sales in five years
from this old factory
you will have 16 to 18
lines
those lines are 400 to 600 cups per
minute
they will cost anywhere five to ten
million dollars
and they will take about two years to
build
so then in order to have them you know
you make the calculation so in five
years this is
literally impossible
so if you're going to make it five years
you're probably going to be 2 million
cases a week that means a pallet of
yogurt every 15 seconds
now when you talk about it it's a quiet
place there's nobody there it's an old
place
you can dismiss the idea you say you're
not going to be a billion dollars in
sales in business in five years and stay
hundred percent independent and you will
find all the money you needed
to make this happen that you don't have
to raise penny of capital
and and then you will give the answer to
the world
impossible
but then it slowly starts happening
toilets turn into office park parking
lot turns into a cooler space with the
trailers
you find user used fillers somewhere
else and people find it in their
nighttime
and
we literally turned that place into that
place and i had no no previous
experience of doing so so what i can
tell you in a short answer
is
i found magic and purpose
and i found magic and
an amazing harmonization of love and
and anger
it's okay to be angry i've been angry
all my life
but if we can channel it through in a
very positive way that becomes an
enormous energy
and
the result of it
i can't put the price of the joy and
benefit that you get from it it's one of
the most beautiful thing that i've been
proud of
of that business effect
on people's life
well clearly a lot of magic happened in
that old factory that you found a 95
year old craft factory
and you decided to take out a small
business loan to purchase the factory to
start producing the yogurt
at the gsb we talk a lot about venture
capital and i'm curious about your
decision to take a small business loan
versus raise vc money
well i didn't know about
that world
i swear i didn't know and
i saw this old factory and i started
wondering how i can buy this
and
there was this key bank's local
johnstown new york key bank regional
sales guys um representatives pat muchi
and john ryder pat mcgee passed away and
john writer is still out there
and i told them i said i want to do the
wrath plan john writer thought that was
a crazy idea stupid
pat muchi this sicilian italian guy most
you know happy big guy he says
i believe you
you're gonna do something i don't know
what but you're gonna do something i'm
gonna help you out and says you have
this sba loan
if you can make a business plan
and you come up with 40
of the
funding that needed
i'm sorry if you if you can come up 10
of the funding that needed the bank will
come up with 40
and the sba will provide the 50 loan
guarantee so we can fund a million bucks
you can buy this factory so the fact it
was 700 000 and i needed 300 000 to
start it
so i wrote my first
business plan
and and basically that's what they did
for me to start buy that factory
later on i got calls
from like 2009 2010
my fear was not that i don't i want to
keep everything to myself
my fear was
um if i bring somebody in
will they
will they affect me
one to crowd my hat with unnecessary
noises and voices and talks and all that
kind of stuff the second one is will
they force me to do things that i don't
want to do
um
so i
i try so hard not to
keep it keep it simple keep it pure
and the business really performed
you know from
2007
october and by 2009
i i kept the business so simple i mean
some people say this is
like i was in quickbooks until 670
million dollars in sales
i'm not kidding
and then
since they changed it i have no idea
what the business is now i have no idea
i understood everything about business
until 6 700 million dollars
that's fair
but i kept it so simple
and and i realized that and i still give
that fight at chobani today
is there's a lot of unnecessary noises
that
happens in boardrooms in
in factory floors and
titles and all that kind of stuff so i i
kept it extremely simple and i'm still
giving that fight
and
i was very cost oriented i was a factory
worker
i did not leave that factory for
seven years more than three days three
days
maybe a month or so for some sales calls
and i was so into every single details
of happening in the factory and the
product and every single detail that you
can think of and when i was
a little crazy maybe i was a little bit
too much but
and there you would find
solu
opportunities problems about to happen
or solution that you need to come up
with
and so that kept it you know really
profitable so i didn't have to raise any
capital
well you took a bet on yourself and on
your ability to bring greek yogurt up to
the united states and it obviously
definitely paid off
but it's easy to forget that in 2010
there were no greek yogurt brands being
advertised on tv and then two years
later there were eight different brands
what did that competition do to you
i knew it was coming and that's what i
said
to anybody who come up with the idea of
the food
items in the united states especially in
the united states it's a very very
challenging environment and i saw this
very very early on so there is
the separation between specialty stores
and the mass market in the united states
but if you go to let's say turkey europe
and other countries
there are some middle market companies
there are regional businesses
there are businesses are not so big but
not so small they have capability to
supply regionally all crossed and and
and and those are almost don't exist in
this country if you're
if you're country-wide system-wide mass
uh food maker
so
early on i really understood that the
big guys they never make innovations
they don't have to so when i started you
have a cup of daniel or you cup of your
plate at the time
you look at it 35 grams sugar
i mean you have the ingredients from top
to bottom i don't know if you guys
remember those days
and they're advertising all day long how
healthy this stuff is
and then you know the cost is extremely
cheap all the factories are made to make
those cubs
and they have all the reasons to keep
that things that way you don't want
anyone to disrupt that and if you look
at mass food environment in this country
which is the reason of a lot of problems
that we're facing today when it comes to
health
is hauled by large corporations large
food corporations that have massive
supply chain capability
an enormous amount
of one-to-one relationship with the
retailers that those are maybe
10 maybe 12 companies that hold
vast majority of food in this that
produced and consumed in this country
because for startups
it's extremely difficult
to create those capabilities so you can
be a true partner with walmart or kroger
or you know safeway so what you become
is a specialty player
so specialty like whole foods and all
that's connected it's only
maybe less than five percent of the
market so the 95 percent of the market
is on the mass
so when somebody comes i have a great
idea good so you just
worked so hard for two years to create
it
and then you went knock door and door
and all these specialty stores and prove
that this works
and the big guys come for two questions
one is do you want to sell
and sometimes you're forced to sell
because all the capital that you raised
until that idea come to life when it
comes to food it's very very capital
incentives intel
capital heavy
uh they come with questions you want to
sell we love what you do four times
sales five times sales whatever it is
but then they come to second half if you
don't i'll make the same thing
it's not your idea anymore it's
everybody's idea so it goes into a big
guy's
uh ability let's say oatmeal came up
like how many oatmeals out there right
everybody can make the oatmeal now so
basically when you have the supply chain
you can be immune to competition if your
brand is very very strong and your value
proposition is very strong and there's
something unique about you but if you
don't have the supply chain
you've got no place to go
so what i said when i saw them i said
they're gonna come
and before they come
i have to make two decisions either one
i want to stay small
or i have to pass a certain level that
they cannot hurt me anymore
and i bet on the second one
so so at that time they were so slow by
the time they came up i was already 6
700 million dollar sales
and i was distributed all across the
country
and i was building a plant in idaho but
when they came they came really really
really hard because you just embarrassed
one of the largest yogurt maker in the
world
you know
in a very bad way so they say
you know i understand somebody come up
with an idea and make some nice noises
in whole foods and all those places but
now i'm losing shares in stop and shop
in costco this is not nice
so
so we have to be
very i always tell
my colleagues we have an incubator you
say you have to focus on manufacturing
fundamentals when you are in the food
business
so at chobani people think that i built
a yogurt and flavors
90 of the time i spent is factories
supply chain
these boring details that nobody wants
to talk about but in the end if you're
going to disrupt any category in this
country
which has not been disrupted in a
massive way if you look at it
you have to focus on the supply chain
well clearly you were able to disrupt
the the industry
and rise above the the competition all
the while still focusing on the human
spirit and not just focusing on the
spreadsheets as you've said before
and an incredible example of that of not
just looking at the spreadsheets is your
decision to grant
shares to all 2000 employees including
factory workers in 2016. i'm sure there
were some people who were not thrilled
with that decision but you made it
anyway
what was your thinking there
i always said
and it's still considered like as if i'm
the nice guy i give a gift
and i have seen this
unjust
from me growing up and becoming an you
know young adult in university
and this in turkey and
and later on here is irresponsibility of
business
what i saw in that little town
is that factory was there for like you
said 80 95 years
when the things were good
the steam was coming off from the
chimney
and the products were going and the
trucks were coming and people had jobs
when things didn't look good somebody
made a decision in a headquarter
that if we cut off this business and
you know we'll save so much money and
those people left behind
so why is this factory workers
this
and in this pandemic we saw
we call them frontline workers but who
are they are truck drivers factory
workers nurses and all those people that
some of them are parents some of it
uh are our relatives
uh that they move the society forward
but when the bad days comes in business
they're the first one to be blamed
so in my scenario four factory workers
later on 10 later on 50 later on 100
with me
we built that things back together
i've never made that promise because i
didn't know
if i could make that false promise i
didn't know if i would be succeed so i
don't want to give some but when i knew
that we had it it was the decision i
made day one
that everyone who worked to build this
have right to have
a share of it or or
or part of the success that we have
generated
and
i truly believe
in this new way of looking at
uh business and what it means in society
but it comes an enormous amount of
strong
effect on how society moves forward and
and businesses are behaving that way but
this income inequality between working
people
and people on top
is getting even in this country
it's getting deeper and sharper and
that's the only way you can save that is
governments can do policies and all that
kind of stuff
but if we can make businesses to share
um its success
with the stakeholder and most
importantly with its workers
is the only way moving forward and i
hope that this becomes uh you know
a very normal practice not that you brag
about it
it's the same way all the startups that
happen in here in silicon valley it's a
very common things
but it's not common when it comes to
vast majority of
service industry manufacturing industry
and especially in our food industry
you've said before that
social impact needs to be a key part of
a company's dna and you clearly
represent that from the top down but do
you have some examples of how that's
represented from the bottom up
how is it represented from bottom up uh
if you could give like so
the kind of impact that maybe a factory
worker can have on making social impact
part of the identity
um yeah i think
um
if if
there's this magic world culture
and
and and i've i've seen a lot of things
that people talk about culture people
talk about all this diversity inclusion
things that we offer what's in the
handbook of employee handbooks and what
do we write in the walls and all that
kind of stuff
the funny thing about culture is
it's either real or it's just not there
or it's just it's in the walls and it's
in the papers
when it's real
then
everybody
uh
is committed to be part of it that there
is this unspoken rule that starts
happening in that environment
and
for the founders you'll be a founder a
lot of people will be founded here
is the cultures are built
mostly in the very early beginning
so i say
the first
few years
and what happens in the first few years
is
you are very intensely together and it's
very close
and there's a lot of conversation
happens
and you face a lot of challenges and you
find a lot of solutions and then you
kind of come into close to almost
die you know finish the whole thing
in those environments
the real you come out how you behave in
those environments
there's a recording is happening during
that time
and those stories been told later on
forever
so what
what what i what i can say is
my early few years were so intense
and i was so present
and i'm so proud of myself
i really am i'm not proud of a lot of
things i've done but i'm really proud of
the first few years that i was in there
i was in a
meeting in the second or third year
and i gather all our employees and these
are all
you know upstate new york
harley drivers big guys
some of them
and i brought them all in the cafeteria
and i said we just started something
magical
i can see this is going somewhere really
really good
but i'm not sure if i can handle this
i have never been part of this before
so i said i don't have anyone around me
i don't have a mother i don't have wife
i don't have girlfriend i don't have
children i don't have family members i'm
alone
so i have you you're my family
and if you see me
i go in a wrong way
if you see me i act in the wrong way
like nose up in the air start behaving
like i'm a big guy big shot and
start doing weird stuff
i give permission every single one of
you they hit me on the face
i literally said that and there are some
big guys
and i said you would give me a service
if you do that
because i don't want this magic to done
and i'm not sure if i can handle it i'm
just a human being
and
nobody hit me
yet but
[Applause]
um
i think
i think
if i go back there is maria there is
rick
there's mike there's frank
there's there's i can name
a lot of people in that place that has
significant
kyle
significant
impact on chobani
as much as i am
but their names are not
mentioned in newspapers and they're not
sitting here next to you so what i'm
saying is um
if you create that culture
every single individual contributes as
as big as what you do
well that's great and you've shared
their names here today and i'm sure they
they really appreciate that
another area you've had amazing impact
is with refugees
and 30 percent of chobani's
manufacturing force are refugees or
immigrants
unfortunately not everyone is as
welcoming of these communities as you
are so could you maybe share a statistic
or an argument that you have found to be
most effective in convincing people to
change their minds i'm so happy you
brought this up
so tent
came out of
this experience that i had in
upstate new york when we expand the
factory and hire everybody that was was
go before
expand a little bit further and then hit
the town in utica which i used to live
and people said there are refugees that
settled in utica
and this is
2008-2009 that area
from all across the world legally being
settled as refugees they're having very
much hard time to find jobs
so i found that i went to settlement
refugee agency and i said what's what's
the problem
actually this heavenly lady she said um
they don't speak the language
they don't have cars
they don't have trainings of jobs that
are available here but most importantly
people really are
a little
you know i said what is it afraid of
them or what is that you know
people are not familiar with people
coming from asia and africa and middle
east this is a rural community
i said okay
i need workers i had everyone in my
community that that is available
uh let's do something so we'll get some
cars and buses we'll get some
translators
and
we will see how that goes and say are
you sure i said yeah i i think this will
be good
so that we started
not at refugee work it was a community
work where people are left behind left
out and they have no way of getting in
and just breaking those barriers but
just
cars translators and in-job training
it's an hr work really it's not a big
deal and said let's just bring them in
and let's people to get to know each
other and interact with each other
and it became this thing
and it brought so much energy to the
company
people loved it a
brotherhood sisterhood was built and
people have never had seen someone from
nepal or someone from ethiopia or
someone from south america
and it was so magical and i just saw
things are happening like
i couldn't believe in my eyes so when i
built a plant in idaho did the same
thing
and then we saw three years later four
years later
and people would come to me tell me
about their experiences i just bought
home my
my my my daughter is in this school
so this magic of having an access to job
for a refugee is the moment that they
stop being a refugee
that is the only moment they start being
part of a community they start being
part of a society they can build their
life for themselves and for their
children so i thought how could i take
this
experience that i had
into a large scale so i went to
switzerland
and talk to you in hdr and irc and some
other things and what i realized the
absence of business
in this refugee topic
which is
probably one of the most alarming
humanitarian crises that we are facing
today
we have faced this during the
you know world war ii when the europe
had so much refugees especially jewish
refugees are fleeing all over the world
and humanity did not perform well at
that time and this is again happening
and it's happening a lot of places
and i thought
the other saddest thing is how this
topic is being part of political
conversations and how is performed you
know profiled as
so unfairly
so bad
and the only way you can cut this
through is if you can tie it into a
power of brands and businesses and ceos
which today have more respect and
believability rates than anybody else
so i launched it with
airbnb joe has been
you know amazing on this topic airbnb
has been amazing mastercard
ig has been amazing on this from very
early on
and and few others in davos in 2016 and
what i said is
we'll do scientific studies
uh we've done a lot with stern you know
business schools and
some economists and branding people we
did market research in each market
europe south america us canada
and
demographics and we said here
statistics are
refugees are staying in the job
30 to 40 times 40 longer than anybody
else
productivity level
and we have done all these studies is
uh twice more than anyone you will have
um and then every dollar you spend on
refugees in five years the longest
usually is a lot earlier than that the
longest in any society in five years
pays back and then
positive after forever
all these studies we've done and then
with the marketing studies and say how
people think about your brand and your
company if you hire refugees trained
refugees then you're pro refugees
and we found we did all these market
studies and found that
what it does to bran brand
and what it does to talent coming into
your company when they know you're you
know socially active in the refugee
field
so by one by one we convince companies
to come and join today we are over 200
companies worldwide
and when the afghanis were coming you
know refugees from afghanistan just a
month ago
we had over 60 companies signed up
publicly
very beautifully and and and committing
to hire refugees trained them right
right away so this this coalition that
we have built together
they became extremely powerful it's the
first business coalition has been built
now
if you talk to anybody
we've been to colombia we've been to
canada we've been to you know
refugee camps all over the world
if you look at if you talk to the
companies that who have gone into this
businesses enormous amount of effect
internally in the company that you have
so it's really really good for business
and i don't find any other way other
than businesses
you know
coming into these topics and any other
topics that society is facing and make
it part of their hr department part of
their manufacturing and people
department or service department
and it's not check the box is
organically you know embedded into
operation then you can see the light
under the tunnel but it's very early
beginning i am extremely passionate
about it
and i think these people have been gone
through so much
pain and sorrow
and difficulties
that they didn't want to leave they
didn't want to go through this but now
they are in these
un
stuck places
that human capacity and potential
through business they can
come into society they can come into
their life and rebuild their life
and the businesses can benefit and
society can benefit from this
so it's very simple hire them
train them
and use your supply chain to keep them
in the uh in in the wherever they are
into the supply chain
and and you'll benefit greatly
well i love that your answer has
statistics to back you up absolutely but
of course as always you're speaking from
the heart and focusing on the human
spirit there
and our theme for this slate of speakers
this year has been going beyond going
beyond expectations of a ceo or a leader
and i think you've done an incredible
job of exemplifying that so thank you
thank you and i
i am i'm so honored to be with you and
with you all
um
i have not
uh graduated from university so i i'm
not yet
um
but um enormous amount of respect to
this institution enormous amount of
respect that solutions and innovations
and the way that
how to form humanity and society better
through innovation and business coming
out of the society you guys are
inspiring us all
it's the most amazing thing
and
being here being with you is is
something that i will not forget and
thank you for the invitation to thanks
thanks thanks for this moment thank you
great we are now going to move to some
questions from the audience
thank you so much for being here and
inspiring us i love the
your comment about the joy
and creating a culture from the
beginning
so my question to you is
giovanni is doing so much and i'm trying
to go for front in so many so many
topics
and
there are two things that capture my
attention when looking at what they're
doing one is this incubator for new
businesses and when i first read out
it's like oh wow
they're actually funding other companies
who could be competition
so i wanted to ask you a little bit
about that initiative of the incubator
and also what would you like to see more
in the sector
to help move move and push this
initiative forward what a beautiful
question
i find
food in
in the us
is one of the fundamentals a problem
that we need to solve
and
the problem is you can make food that is
very good ingredients but it's very
expensive people cannot afford it
and and then the big guys they make very
bad food it's very accessible so how do
you make accessible food that is
wholesomely made is it nutritionally
made that every children every family
members across the country can have it
so that was my thing is
good food for all delicious nutritious
natural and accessible because you can
make five dollars yogurt but how many
people are gonna buy that
um so
what i did is we found a way
like we found we found a way to make a
dollar a yogurt
that made
extremely wholesome ingredients that
have 11 gram protein
uh that available in walmart for one
dollar or kroger for 1.20 but everybody
can buy
so i wanted to share that
with the with the startups
so i started the uh they found the
incubator choban incubator and i said no
string attached i don't want
anything
back i don't want any percentage or
anything all i want to do is if i was
starting my journey in 2007 the things
that i wish i had known back then
what would those be
and i made a list of five
kind of five or seven
and i wanted to share those with people
who are starting their journey that had
the like-minded entrepreneurs they have
the right attitude and they see the same
thing
and we started this it became very very
popular and incubated people will come
four months five months stay with us
engineering
quality plants branding marketing all
the doors are open for all of them and
we had
an amazing woman founders came veterans
founders came
and and the farmers farmers and
entrepreneurs came and i started with
turkey too i did it for four years
i brought 30 students from turkey from
all across the country
and then
five six startups every year that was
the summer program
i think one of the most beautiful things
we can do is share the experience and
knowledge without string being any
string attached
and open it up
so the second reason i had is we cannot
be alone on this we have we need a
community so that's that's the reason
either another yogurt maker another food
maker and whatever it is
this new good food making movement for
for all
has to be a communities for us to maybe
be able to make a dent into this problem
so i thought
we might not be as big as the other big
guys but if we are part of a community
and we collaborate with each other we
share from each other
then we can really make this a mass
thing so that was the second reason that
i started it
hi i'm the this is me that from istanbul
i'm also a fan of fun
so thank you very much for coming here
and sharing your uh insights about
entrepreneurship and impact
uh and i would like to
like your
comments on like being an international
immigrant entrepreneur in the us was
very important and was very
truly inspiring for all the
international students who want to start
businesses here and i would like to ask
like what would be your top three tips
for them to start like great businesses
in the us
uh what a great
question with that um
really get to know america
and
what i can suggest
for
people like us coming from outside
for the americans there's politics there
is celebrity there is footballs and all
that kind of stuff that's a different
thing
but for us
we come with pre-judgments
and those judgments can be because of
what we read
because of the political background we
come from whatever that might be
and and i tell this to refugees to
get rid of all those pre ideas
get to know america if this is what you
want to live in
and i say that because this missile is
extremely easy i don't like this i don't
like what they do here i don't like what
they do here
but if you look at it for the large part
we are the same
right so
when i went upstate new york worked in
that farm i in new york city i couldn't
there's more turks in new york city than
you know
natives um
so it's turkey in new york city if you
want to stay in turkey but when i was
upstate new york
these farmers the people have been there
for generations you get to know this the
soil you get to know the culture you get
to know the background
and
start loving apple pie
and thanksgiving the magic of
thanksgiving like i was amazed by
it interactions of the farmers with each
other
i was amazed by it
and
and i celebrated those a lot and it get
me to when i started celebrating then i
i started to get to know the people and
the culture and the history
and i think
in the entrepreneurship there's a little
bit of anthropology
is really involved in it
and and that is your own experience with
people
without the judgment to understand
and people look at chobani they think
that we are you know very liberal
activist brand you have to understand
our two plans in upstate new york and
idaho they're seventy eighty percent red
states red areas
and these are one of my closest brothers
and sisters
we made human connections because we
understood each other
i still make my argument that that
should be
you know
minimum wage
uh with the idaho government i usually
make an argument that when they ban
transgenders in the schools and i
strongly disagree with that
but in the in a human level we
understand each other we can sit down
and break bread and talk about things
and i can still celebrate the deep
culture of idaho in a family level and
in other other levels so what are my
recommendation is truly try to
understand and you'll find more beauty
than you ever imagined especially in the
rural areas especially in the family
interactions
is that some not so good things of
course it's everywhere
so that's my first and the second one is
don't try to be like them
stay who you are
what you brought where you come from are
so beautiful so amazing and so valuable
and this country celebrates that
tremendously
so how do you make sure that what you
see
and what you bring that can beautifully
homogenize with each other
i never forgot being a shepherd's son
from eastern part of turkey i never
forgot that boy
and if i go back tomorrow and if i put a
mask on and nobody recognize me i can go
to that mountain
and start being under that tent
and be with the shepherds and they would
never know i left
because i never forgot that i lived that
every single day
so you don't have to leave who you are
to become successful for another place
the most successful person is brings the
beauty of where you come from
and to take and homogenize it here and i
always said i brought a seed from where
i come and i found a beautiful soil here
and that's become a
this plant
hamdi hi my name is yvonne thank you so
much for being here i'm a second year
in the 45 or 50 minutes we've been with
you you've connected so well with us
and i'm curious as a ceo and founder
do you draw lines with your people and
if so when do you do that and how do you
know what lines to draw
thank you um
look i i think i think we have to be
there's there's um thank you i was
smiling on my undermine
um and so so gracious thank you so much
um yes
um look as long as they know you're real
it's okay to be angry it's okay to draw
the lines it's okay to
have tough conversations
and as long as it's not personal i
always said i mean my colleague nishal
is here
and i love him he's we've done wonders
together and we have tough times
together
and as long as he knows i'm angry about
the thing not at him
and
and
we have not written a lot of rules in
the company but there's a lot of knowns
one thing that i have no
i have no
passion for is disrespect
like that just
either in a social environment or inside
the company
to
talk about one of your colleagues in a
very disrespectful way or making
somebody uncomfortable in the space
is something that i think that is poison
in business field if that is it exists
and that i have i mean that is one of
them second one is when somebody
suggests preservatives in food
that's just like no that [ __ ] is not
gonna happen
um
and um
i think
um introduction of poison in a very
small way in the business field and
sometimes it's just a tiny thing those
things later on grows and becomes a
really big thing so if you are very
strong and i have i have
relaxed certain things along the way
which i thought that was really big
thing for that time but not necessarily
right now like i had this thing
that
if i open a cup of yogurt and if i see
yogurt on the lid i'll get so upset
people were so scared of it
so i will i will go to the store and i
open the yogurt and i see the yogurt on
the lid i said that means that we have
not done our feeling right those fillers
were so so fast
so i would go and give so much
bad time for our operation people
and i give up so who gives a really [ __ ]
about it but it's okay
there's trucks and there's people are
if they're buying it if they put in
their shopping bag it's going to happen
anyway so there are things that is not
realistic
but
um i i really do believe um
the the the the having real
conversations sometimes
not pleasant conversation is totally
fine and totally okay we are not a
foundation we are real business and i
never i always wanted to tell people i'm
not an ngo
this is not an ngo this is this is a
business
and it has to self-sufficient itself
and every year 10 of the people will
leave let go or fired whatever that is
it's just function of business
and i think we need to know that
if you're going to build and to a
society where business
finds a way to solve this fundamental
problems and be part of it it cannot
behave like an ngo
it's a real business and i don't know if
you want to put a tagline of the social
enterprise or this and that
i don't have to sound like i'm i'm from
church or i'm from saved america or save
the children i don't have to i'm
business i innovate
i compete
i don't like my competitors
if they're so good i'll find a way to
hate them one way or another
uh kidding aside
this is the excitement part of business
that gives me get going is i can think
about things how i can win the battles
in the shelf for the right reason it
makes it even better
but the field of business is something
that
you will not find in anybody else where
you can put all your capability
leadership innovation human connection
interaction teamwork
i don't know you name it that the places
that you touch
it's just amazing it's especially if
you're a founder or if you're a founding
partner
so it's an amazing place so let's keep
it business but
there has to be
a silent
language
knowledge or conviction or everyone
agrees
that we operate this within these
boundaries
we know why we do what we do we don't
have to talk about and brag about it all
the time
we know that we are safe and we are all
together and this is our space everybody
is in here
and we know that we have some certain
performances that we have to do it and
if we don't it's not going to be
punishment we're going to find a way to
do it together but those boundaries can
be created and within that we'll have
some pleasant conversation and some not
pleasant conversation i think that's
totally fine
thank you to the students for those
great questions
hamdi i noticed that you often wear what
is important to you on your head and so
an honor to
honor your time with us here today oh my
god i got a special gsb hat that
actually says view from the top on the
back so thank you so much for your time
and
and in my personal life i always wear
hats
and i wear three hats always one is
chobani
today i decided to come here with my
tent hat because i'm extremely
passionate about tent also and the third
one is my my
colleagues from turkey would know
fenerbahce my soccer team
but chobani is my first love so i'll
present you this and thank you
thank you
you